hi I'm Bo in this video I will be going
over some common data structures and
algorithms in JavaScript I'll be showing
you how to implement them in JavaScript
so if you want to see the exact list you
can check the description and I have
links to all the code in the description
as well so let's get started
a stack of books is a great example of
the stack data structure if you make a
stack of books the topmost book in the
stack was the one that you put there
last if you remove that book from your
stack stop you would expose the book
that was put there before the last book
stacks are of last in first out type of
service the last book you put on top of
a stack would be the first book you take
off the stack another example of the
stack is your browsers back button if
you look up here we just opened up
facebook.com so we add it to the top of
the stack of sites that we've already
visited previously would you stack top
push push is one of the stack methods
you push Facebook on top of the stack
this middle is what it looks like when
we are visiting Facebook and then this
bottom image is where we press the back
button to navigate back to Twitter so we
pop off the most recent URL and we just
leave Twitter at the top of it the
function is traditionally provided in
the stack our push for placing data onto
a stack pop for removing the top element
of a stack peak for displaying the top
element of a stack and length or size
for determining how many elements are on
a stack a nice feature of JavaScript is
that the array object already has all
the functions we need in order to use it
as a stack so you could just use an
array as a stack I will show you how to
do this using an array but then I will
actually create a stack class and show
you how that works too
I'm going to use an array stack to find
words that are palindromes a palindrome
is a word that is spelled the same
forwards and backwards such as Bob b.o.b
or racecar RAC eca are okay so we have
our letters equals an empty array and
that's the stack because remember I said
arrays are have all the functions of a
stack so look at how this program works
first we're gonna set a word to be
anywhere we want and we're gonna choose
race car which is a palindrome and then
we are going to have a variable which is
just a empty string for our word or
first word we're going to use the stack
to fill up the r-word variable with the
reverse of the word variable the first
thing we're going to do is put the
letters of the word into the stack so we
have a for loop here and we're going to
start at index 0 and go to the last
index of the word length so an index in
a string is just which character we're
looking at so we're going to do letters
which remember is our stack dot put the
step function where you put something on
top of the stack and we're going to push
word index I so that's just going to
take this for loop is just going to take
each letter of our word because we have
an X 0 and X 1 and X 2 each letters new
index and push it on to the letter stack
now we're going to pop off the stack in
reverse order so we can create the
r-word variable which is the reverse of
the word variable another for loop and
now we are going to have the R word and
we're going to add one letter at a time
from the stack by popping off the top
letter and because they were put in
order they're going to be popped off in
reversed order now we have a string that
should be the reverse of the first word
so word and our words to be reverse of
each other now to check it's a
palindrome we just say if our word
equals equals equals word it is a
palindrome over else it's not a
palindrome so let's run that and see
what happens and racecard is a
palindrome but if we change that to free
code yeah and run that nope it's not a
palindrome okay that was just a basic
usage of a stack using an array now I
will show you how to implement a stack
in JavaScript so you can understand
stacks a little more you probably would
never do that because you can use an
array as a staff but this should
possibly help you understand how stacks
work a little better so here's where
we're going to create the stack which is
going to be this function here we're
going to have two variables this that
count
and this that storage now this storage
is an empty object and count is gonna
keep track of how many items are in the
stack so here are all the different
methods we have pushed this step push is
going to add a value to the end of the
stack you're gonna pass end the value
this that storage or storage is the
empty object at the end X this that
count we are going to add the value so
we're gonna put the value on the top of
the stack or the end of the stack and
then we're just going to increment count
up one so now it's showing that we have
another item in the stack the next
function we're going to remove and
return the value at the end of the stack
or at the top of the stack which is the
stuff top this is gonna pop an item off
so if this that count equals equals zero
that means there's nothing of the stack
and we're going to return undefined
because there is nothing in the stack
once we return undefined right we're not
gonna do anything it the rest of this
code here because we've already returned
from this function if we're popping off
something we're going to have to
decrement the count so it's a count
minus one so one less we're gonna set
the result to this that storage which is
the object for our stack and index this
count which is the last item in the
stack and then we're going to delete
that item and we're gonna return result
so you get the last item back but it
will be deleted off of the stack and
there's just a few more methods this dot
size is going to return this that count
which is the number of items in the
stack and then the last function is this
that peak which is going to return the
value at the end of the stack but it
will not remove it like pop so peek and
pop are kind of similar but pop removes
the item and peek does not remove the
item so return this dot storage and then
this that count minus one this that
count would actually be they'll index
one after the final item because what
that's where you would add in a new item
but you would have to do minus 1 to get
the last item and if you're peeking you
do not want to pass in the value so let
me take that bad off there so you only
pass in the value when you're pushing in
something
let's see how this would work down here
okay we are going to create a variable
called my stack which is a new stack
which is what we just defined up there
we're gonna push one on to it to the top
don't push two on the top so it's just a
stack with one and then two we're going
to peak and we're gonna have to console
dot log this because it's going to just
return the top number of the staff which
should be two now we're gonna pop off to
so it's going to return to again
but it's gonna remove it and if we peek
will she be back to one and before we
run that I forgot these extra
parentheses here because these are
functions and need the parentheses at
the end of all functions so let's try
that okay see we peaked at two we popped
off two and then when we peaked again it
was one because two was was removed now
you can also add other things to the
stack
now I'm going to push a string onto the
stack and we're going to check the size
then want a peak and I'm gonna pop it
off anyway a peak again so let's see
what that does
so we push the one we push to repeat
with show two we pop whoosh pop off too
we peaked again which showed one so
there's only one thing in the stack then
we pushed free code camp to string and
we console dot log the size and now this
item to the stack is just one on the
bottom and then free code camp on the
top we're going to peak which is going
to show free coke camp now we're going
to pop which is going to pop off and
show freako camp and they're gonna peak
again and we'll see that it's just one
on the bottom well those are the basics
of stack
the set data structure is kind of like
an array except there are no duplicate
items and the values are not in any
particular order the typical use first
set is to simply check for the presence
of an item I'm going to show you how to
implement a set function bf6 actually
has a built in set object however the
built in set objects does not contain
all the methods that are common to sets
so you may still have to implement part
of the set yourself depending on what
you're gonna use it for when I show you
the implementation for the set I will
tell you which methods are part of the
es6 set and which are not so we're just
gonna go through this code we're gonna
call it my set now we could call it set
but I want to make it different than the
es6 set so this is my set so here's just
the collection this set is gonna be a
collection of items and we're gonna
store them in an array which an array
can't have duplicate items but we're
gonna implement this in such a way that
you cannot add duplicate items to this
array this method the method has is
gonna check for the presence of an
element and then return true or false
so you have passed in the element and
it's going to do collection that index
of element is not negative one so if the
element is not in the collection it's
gonna return negative one so if it
doesn't return negative one it's true so
if it's not negative one it's true that
means the element is in the array else
it's false now we have the values this
is going to return all the valleys of
the set pretty straightforward just
return the collection now I've add we're
gonna add an element to this set but
first we have to check if the Elm is in
the set already so we're gonna call the
the method we've already defined that
has method and see if the collection has
the element if it does not have the
element then we can add it we're gonna
push that element to that collection
array and we're gonna return true else
we're gonna return false so if we don't
push an element to the collection we're
returning false now we have removed this
is going to remove an element so first
we just check if the element is in
the collection and if it is in the
collection we're gonna find out what the
index of the element is and then we're
gonna remove it splice is means we're
gonna take out we're gonna take out an
element in the array starting at the
index of the element and going for one
element we're gonna take out one element
and then we're gonna return true or
we're gonna return false if that element
is not in the collection then we're just
going to return the size of the
collection we're just going to turn
collection that length every method
we've gone through so far is in the es6
implementation of the set so the es6 set
has values add remove in size except
remove is delete in the ex6 set instead
of calling remove you're gonna call
delete but all the other things are
included another thing is size is not a
method in the es6 set size is a property
that just means that when you're calling
it you're not going to put parenthesis
at after the the method because it's
just a property so you can do set that
size and sort of set that size with
parentheses after it okay now we're
going to get into the methods that are
not in the es6 implementation of the set
but are often included in sets the next
few methods actually just help you work
with sets and when you're working with
two different sets so we have Union this
method is going to return the union of
two sets so it's gonna combine the sets
but leave out any duplicates in the
combination of the sets so we're gonna
call the Union method on the original
set or I'm gonna pass in the other set
that we want to combine we're gonna
create a new set which this should be my
set same what's down here because we
want to make it distinct from the es6
set so we have the the Union set which
is just a new set that's what we're
going to combine the sets into we have
the first step which is this stop values
and the values were just calling the the
values
that up here to return the collection
and the second set is going to be the
other set that values for a new first
set for each and for each value in that
set we're gonna do a union set that add
to add the value then we do the same
thing second set for each and for each
value in the second set we're going to
add the value remember the add method
already does not add the value if it's a
duplicate so the Union set now will not
contain any duplicates and since for the
set data structure the order doesn't
matter we don't have to have the values
in any particular order and then we're
going to return the Union set now we
have intersection which is going to
return the intersection of the two sets
as a new set so we're gonna make a new
set here intersection set equals new my
set the first set again we're gonna call
the best values to get all the values in
the first set now for each value in the
first set we are going to check if the
other set has the value we are going to
add it and then we're going to return
the intersection set so the intersection
is just all the items that are in both
sets and that's we're gonna return that
as a new set and this next function
we're also gonna have to add them my
there so this is the difference so the
difference between the sets so all the
items that are in one set but not the
other set so we're gonna create a new
set again the different set and again
we're gonna get the values of the first
step now this is very similar to the
intersection we're going to go through
each value in the first set and if the
other set does not have the value
remember up here we were seeing its
other set hand the value now we're gonna
use the not operator the exclamation
point to see if the value is not in the
set and we're going to add that to the
different set then we'll return the
different set and the last method we're
going to talk about is the subset and
this is going to test if the set is a
subset of a different set so it's going
to test
the first set is completely contained
within the second set so it's just gonna
return true or false so we're gonna pass
in the other set we're gonna again get
all the values of the first set and
we're going to call this function first
set that every and what that every
method is going to do is going to test
whether all the elements in the array
pass the tests implemented by the
provided function so we're gonna test if
all the elements in the first set will
pass this function which is other set
that has value are all the elements in
the first set are they in the second set
so we're gonna see if the first set is a
subset of the second set so that's the
set data structure and let's quickly
just show you some some uses of the set
so we have set a as my new my set set B
is new my set we're going to add to set
a a look edit set B B we had to set BC
or ad to set B a and we're going to add
to set B D and now we're gonna see if
set a is a subset of set B so is set a
is every item in set a which is actually
just the letter a and set B which it is
because it's right here let's run that
and it should say true let's do some
other things okay and this is the set a
that intersection set B is going to
return a new set which we are then going
to call the values function so we can
see all the valleys in that set and it's
just a because the only value that's in
both set a and set B is a but we can do
a lot of the same things with the built
in set I'm gonna copy all this instead
of long that's my set or just going to
be half set we're gonna do set C and set
D
[Music]
okay so here's one difference with the
es6 set is that when you call the values
method instead of returning an array
it's going to return an iterator so you
can see objects set iterator here and
then you can still iterate through all
the items in the array besides that all
the other methods that a set has are
very similar to the methis ette that we
implemented so we can do set D delete
now this is instead of remove so we're
gonna delete the a and then we're going
to cancel that log and check if that D
has a and we can see it's false because
it's been deleted and we can also try to
add D which is already in the set oh and
there is one final thing that's
different with the es6 implementation
the add method is not gonna return true
or false whether the item has been added
or not besides adding the item what it's
going to return so whatever it was it's
gonna cancel that log is is the set
itself it's not an array of the set it's
going to return the full set so if we
run that you can see here it's going to
return the set which is an object and
since it's an object it's not gonna show
all the different items in this set okay
that's the set data structure
the queue data structure is a way to
hold data it's similar to a stack while
a stack is first in last out a queue is
first in first out an example in real
life is when you were waiting in line to
buy something in a store the first
person to get in the line is the first
person to get to the cash register
another example is a print queue when a
lot of people are printing documents at
the same printer the documents are
printed in the order they were sent to
the print queue in JavaScript just like
a stack you can implement a queue with
just an array if you want a limit and
array to just the traditional queue
methods you must create it yourself let
me show you one such implementation so
we have the queue right here and we're
going to have a collection that's going
to collect all the items in the queue
and this is just kind of a helper
function to print or it's a console that
log the collection and here that the
main main methods of a queue we have in
queue which is going to push the first
item onto the queue and then we have DQ
which is going to take an item off the
queue so there's two ways to do it with
an array items can go into the array at
the beginning of the array or items can
go in the array at the end of the array
in this implementation items are going
into the array at the end of the array
and then they come off of the array at
the beginning of the array to put an
item onto the queue we're just going to
push that I know that element onto the
queue then to DQ we're going to use the
rage IFFT dot shift just pulls off the
first item of the array it removes the
first item of the array and returns it
another cue method is front this is just
going to return what item is at the
front of the array without removing the
item off of the array so we're just
gonna do collection output just going to
return what items at the at the zero
index of the collection array and size
we just try to figure out the size of
the queue pretty straightforward just
collection that length and then is empty
check if it's empty if there's not no
items on the queue so let's see how that
was gonna work
here I'm just gonna uncomment that and
run the code so we in cute we created a
new Q then we Inc we in cute ABC so the
line the end of the line is the end of
the array the beginning of the line is
the beginning of the array so it's gonna
print a B C here and then D Q means that
the item at the beginning of the array
is gonna to be removed so the a is going
to be removed and then we're gonna do
cute out front which I forgot to put
that console.log here okay run that
again you'll see that it's going to
check what what elements at the front of
the array which is B and I'm gonna print
the array again it's just me B and C
because we DQ'd a another way to create
a queue is a priority queue in a
priority queue not only do you pass the
element into the queue you also pass the
priority of the element so if all the
priorities are the same number it's
going to behave just like a normal queue
but when you pass in elements at
different priorities the elements that
are passed in with a higher priority are
sent to the beginning of the queue so
all elements with priority 5 are ahead
of elements with priority 4 but if
elements have the same priority it just
behaves like a normal Q so let me
explain how the priority queue works
first let me show you an example of this
code down here where we're using the
priority queue so to create the priority
queue and then we're going to in queue
something and so we're gonna pass in an
array the first element in the array is
the item we want to put on to the
priority queue the second thing in the
array is the priority so you can see I'm
not pushing them on in the same order
two three one but if I run this when we
that print the collection it's going to
print in the order of the priority and
just to show another example let me add
an item with the same priority as an
item we already have
and if I run that you can see these two
items have the same priority so they're
in the queue in the order that they were
pushed on to the queue so everything's
the same on a priority queue except the
in queue function so in the in queue
function first we're going to check if
the queue is empty if it's empty you're
just going to push on the element but if
it's not empty you're gonna have to
check the priorities to see where to put
the element on so we're gonna create a
variable just to check whether we've
added the item to the queue or not and
it would fall it starts at false and now
we're gonna have to run through each
element in the the collection or the
queue to check what the priorities are
so we have this floor loop that's gonna
run through each item in the collection
and we're gonna check is the element at
index one remember the element that we
pass into the queue is an array index
zero is the item you want to put into
the queue and index one is the priority
so is the priority of the element we're
passing into the queue less than the
priority of the item in the collection
that we're checking and see we're using
this eye from the for loop we're gonna
go through and check every item in the
collection and we're going to check the
index 1 which is the priority of that
item and then if the priority is less
than the item we're going to add that
item or the element to the collection
array that's what this splice is doing
and then we're gonna say add it equals
true we're gonna break out of the loop
here and then we're gonna be done except
if the element hasn't been added we are
going to then push the element to the
array and the only thing that's slightly
different is this DQ method and this is
the way I did is kind of optional you
could return the entire element with the
item and the priority or you can do an
idea where I just returned the item
without the priority here
that's just index 0 of this value which
is the the items that we got off the
beginning of the array well those are
cues and priority queues
a tree data structure is a way to hold
data that when visualized looks like a
tree you would see in nature now this is
actually what we visualized a tree data
structure to look like all data points
in the tree are called nodes the top of
the tree is called the root node and
from here it branches out into
additional nodes each of which may have
more child nodes and so on nodes with
branches leading to other nodes are
referred to as the parent of the node of
the branches that leads to the child
leaf nodes are nodes at the end of the
tree that have no children also any
children of a node are parents of their
own sub tree in this video we will be
covering a specific type of tree called
a binary search tree while the tree data
structure can have any number of
branches at a single node for instance C
the C here there's F G H it has three
branches at a single node a binary tree
however can only have two branches for
every node so look down here here's a
binary tree each node only has two
branches also binary search trees are
ordered each subtree is less than or
equal to the painter node and each right
subtree is greater than or equal to the
parent node because they use the
principle of binary search on average
operations are able to skip about half
of the tree so that each lookup
insertion or deletion takes time
proportional to the logarithm of the
number of items stored in the tree this
is much better than the linear time
required to find items by key in an
unsorted array but slower than the
corresponding operations on a hash table
so let's see how this works in
JavaScript here we're going to use
classes to create the binary search tree
basically we're going to create two
classes the no class in the BST or
binary search tree class the no class
represents each node in the tree and
there's any three data properties we
have the data which is what we're
actually trying to store and we have
this that left and this that right which
are going to point to the left node and
the right node so in the binary search
tree we're going to have the constructor
which just creates the the root node
which is the top of the tree which it
starts as null and then we're gonna have
the add function so
this is how we are going to add
something to the tree so we're gonna add
the data we're going to get a reference
to the root node but if this is the
first node node will be null in that
case we're just gonna set the root node
to the new note the new data we just put
in so new node data so we're just gonna
create a node based on that data if it's
not the first node we're gonna have to
figure out where to put this node in the
tree to figure out where to place the
new node we are going to use a recursive
function so I'm gonna create this
function which is search tree we're
gonna pass in the node which starts off
as a root node if the data we pass in is
less than no dot data that means we're
going to put the note on the left side
of the tree so if the node dot left side
of the tree is null we're just going to
assign node dot left to the new node and
then we'll return but if no doubt left
is not null we're going to return search
tree no doubt left that just means we're
gonna continue searching this is where
it the recursive nature comes in it's
going to run the search tree function
again and continue working down the tree
to find where to put the node and you
can see here else if if the data is more
than no data that means we're gonna put
the note on the right side so if no dot
write equals equals equals null then we
just assign no dot right to the new node
and we can return else if if the node
right does not equal null we're gonna
have to keep searching so we're gonna
return search tree no dot right so else
that means data is not less than no dot
data data is not more than no dot data
so they must be equal if they're equal
we're not going to add the data to the
tree we're just gonna return null so
this is the search tree function and
this is how we initially call the search
tree function return search tree node
which starts out as a root node but then
it can be called with different nodes as
it's going recursively through the tree
let's say you have 50 in your tree and
you have 17 in your
and you want to add 23 first it's going
to see that the note is not null because
you have things in your tree and then
it's going to run the search tree
function putting in the root node which
is 50 then we'll see if data is less
than no dot data which it is because 23
is less than 50 we're gonna go to the
the node dot left if no doubt left is
null we would put it here but it's not
because there's a 17 here remember we're
just adding the number 23 so else if if
left no doubt left does not equal null
which is true we are going to return the
search tree no dot left so we we are now
gonna run this search tree function but
passed in the 17 so now we're gonna see
does is data less than no data
well now date is 23 but no data is 17 so
this is false now we're gonna go down to
this is data more than node data
yeah 23 is more than 17 well is no dot
writeln all in this example we're saying
that 23 isn't there so no dot right
would be null and then we can just set
no dot right to be the new node the next
functions we're going to talk about our
find min and fine max so we're just
gonna be find the minimum of the array
and finding the maximum of the array if
you look at this binary search tree
right here you can see the minimum is
all the way on the left side 9 the math
is all the way on the right side 76 so
just using that knowledge makes it easy
to find men and find max so I'm going to
set the current node to the root node
and so the minutes can get all the way
on the left so while this dot Left does
not equal null the current node is going
to be current dot left and then at the
very end it's gonna return current data
so we're gonna check this if the left
side is not null we're gonna go to the
next one if it's not learn all we're
gonna go to this one if it's not null
when we go to this one now the next is
null because there's nothing to the left
of 9 so we're gonna return current data
we're gonna return the 9 cuz that's the
data on the very left side fine Max is
just the same way but the opposite we're
gonna start at current which is going to
this dot root which is gonna start at
the top while current dot right does not
equal null well this does not equal null
fit at 72 then we're gonna
go to the next loop current equals
current dot right when we go to the next
one but now current that right isn't all
because there's nothing to the right of
76 so we can just return current data
now we have the find function now is
present is very similar but instead of
returning the node we're just gonna
return true or false whether the data is
in the tree so we're starting at the top
they're written out while current that
means while there is a current node
while current is not null we're going to
do the following if data equals equals
equals current that data return true
that means we found it if we haven't
found it we're going to see is data less
than current at data now current equals
current out left so we're gonna start
searching on the left side else
well data must be more than current data
so we're going to start searching on the
right side and we're going to keep
searching and if we never find it if we
never find that data equals equals
current that data and return true that
means is not in the tree and we can
return false
okay the remove function is a little
more complicated than the other
functions we've covered just like in the
add function and their move function
there's gonna be a recursive function so
we're gonna create this function here
kant's remove node equals function where
we're gonna pass in the node and we're
gonna pass in the data which is the data
what we're trying to remove so we have
this whole function here and then here's
where we're gonna call the function at
the end this that root equals remove
node and we're gonna pass in this that
root and data we're assigning this that
root to whatever is returned to this
function here we're gonna pass in the
root node because you always start with
the root node and then the data that
we're searching for so let's see how
that works
first of all we have to check if we have
an empty tree if the node equals null
then we have an empty tree and we can
return null now we're gonna see if does
data equal no data so we're trying to
see if we can find that data in the tree
so if we've found the node with the data
this is what we're gonna do
there's actually three different options
either no one has no children
that would be just like the 76 if
there's no children we just completely
delete that node
so if
no doubt left equals null and no doubt
right equals null then he's there's no
children just returned know when we're
returning null were setting the node
that had that data to null now we're
gonna check if the node just has one
child if node has no left child
if no dot left equals null that'll be
just like this 54 here there's a node on
the right but there's no node on the
Left if node outlet left equals null
then we're just gonna return no dot
right that means we're gonna replace
this node with whatever is on the right
which is 67 so instead of 72 points in
54 that will be replaced with 54 ZnO dot
right which is 67 and if there's no note
on the right we're gonna do the same
thing we're gonna just return the node
that's on the left to be the the new
node that's being pointed to it gets
more complicated when the node has two
children like such as v 17 if you want
to replace node 17 you can't just put in
12 here because then what will happen to
23 is you can't just put in 23 here it
isn't what will happen to 12
so let's look down here this picture
down here is kind of small let's say
we're trying to remove this 3 here that
has the red X in here the way to remove
this node right here would be to replace
it with this node down here so if we
remove 3 we can place we can replace it
with 4 and then everything will be right
with the binary search tree so if you
look at what it would become
over here we just replaced a 4 down here
with the 3 up there but how are we gonna
get down to that 4 well first we have to
go to the right sub node and then we
have to go all the way down to the most
left sub node after we've gone to the
right sub node so let's see that we're
gonna create in node which is going to
be no dot right so in this case the temp
if we're trying to delete the 3 the temp
node would be no debt right which would
be the 6 here well no tip node that left
does not equal null tip node equals no
dot left that means we're gonna keep
first we're gonna go to the right of the
node we're gonna delete and then we're
gonna keep me gonna keep going to the
left until we get to the last one on the
left side and this one just happens
before there's no more to go down
because you just have to go down one but
if there was more to go down to it just
keep hopping down until it got to the
most left node now we're gonna set no
dot data to tip no data so the node is
the three up here so instead of the data
of this node being three the data the
note is now four because Tim no data is
four now I'm gonna set node dot right to
equal and now here we're gonna call the
remove node function again this is where
it starts becoming recursive and we're
gonna pass in the Noda the node on the
right and the tip node data and this
will keep running through the function
and set up the right side of the tree
correctly we see here we were saying if
data equals no data else if data is less
than no dot data that just means we have
to go to the left side of the tree
because it's less and here we're gonna
call we're gonna say that no doubt left
equals remove node and we're gonna call
this recursive function again and pass a
node up left and the data and then we're
gonna return the node else that means
data is more than no data when you know
dot right and then call this recursive
function again and no dot right data and
we're gonna return the num the node so
you can see that the leaf is the most
complicated one that we've covered
especially when one node has two Leafs
so let's look at how you use a binary
search tree at least this one that I've
created so far so let's open up the
console here I'm gonna do Const BST
equals new BST I've created my binary
search tree we're gonna add four at two
six one three five seven and then I'm
gonna remove four and then we're going
to file we're gonna console that log the
min and the max two times and I'm gonna
check to see if 4 is present another
thing we're gonna do is we're I'm gonna
add in you remove seven and we'll run
that again you can see it first it's the
minimum is one it's gonna console that
log max which is seven but then we
remove seven and now the max is going to
be six and we're gonna see is this
present is for present false note 4 is
not present because we've removed in
this video covered all the key methods
common to a binary search tree however
in a future video I'll be going over a
few other things you
such as finding the tree height and
traversing the tree through in order
preorder and postorder traversal if you
want to play around with this code you
can check the link to the code in the
description
finding the tree height and tree
traversal height in a tree represents
the distance from the root node to any
given leaf node so if you look at this
example over here the root node is nine
that's height zero but if you see four
and seventeen here that's height one
three six and twenty two height two five
seven and twenty our height three so
it's the distance from the root node to
the leaf nodes they're kind of like
layers of a cake and that's how you're
gonna count them different paths in a
highly branched tree structure may have
different heights but for a given tree
there will be a minimum height and a
maximum height and if the tree is
balanced these values will differ at
most by one so before I show you the
code to implement those things I'm going
to show you the use of the code we're
going to go all the way down to the
bottom where we create a new binary
search tree and then we add all these
values with the those values they are
the same values as in the picture over
here we're going to find the men height
we're going to find the map site and
we're gonna check if it's balanced let's
just comment out these now so it's only
the men height is one in a console the
mattes that is three and it's not
balanced the men height is the distance
from the root node to the first leaf
node without two children so if you look
on here 17 is a root node without two
children it has a right child but
doesn't have a left child so the minimum
height you started at the root node
which is zero and then you count to the
next level which is one so the min
height is one now the max height is just
the distance from the root node to
whatever the the most bottom node is so
five seven and twenty are all at the max
height so zero one two three so the Mac
side is three now this tree is not
balanced because remember if a tree is
balanced the values between the min
height and the max height will be at
different most by one you can see that
there's a missing number here the reason
why this tree is not balanced is because
there's no number here to the left of 17
but if I uncomment out this code here
we're gonna add ten now ten you see when
it's being added it's going to add to
the left of seventeen because it's more
than nine but it's less than seventeen
so the tin will fill this spot right
here and then we're gonna find the min
height the max site and then check if
it's balanced again okay so now the min
height is two and the max height is
three the min height is going to be
either this three or the ten that we
just add that it's not showing up in the
picture but just imagine there's a 10
right here so we have 0 1 and then the
min height is this level right here
because this is the first level that
there are node without two children if
you imagine there's a 10 right here so
that's 2 and then 3 is out here right
now is balanced is true the difference
between the min height and max height is
at most 1 so it's going to have to be
either 0 or 1 to be balanced when a tree
is balanced then searching through it is
much more efficient we're not going to
cover this in this video but there are
ways that you can make a tree
automatically balance itself when you
add new items and when you delete items
this creates greater efficiency when
searching the tree okay now we're going
to look at these last lines I have to
have commented out here these are ways
to traverse the tree tree traversal
methods can be used to explore tree data
structures and basically find all the
values in the tree in depth-first search
a given sub trees explored as deeply as
possible before the search continues on
another sub tree when I show you an
example it will that will make more
sense but there's basically three ways
that this can be done there's in order
traversal preorder traversal post order
traversal and this last one I'm going to
talk about later this level order
traversal so let me run this and then
I'm going to explain it so here you look
at the bottom of the console and you can
see what we've logged here for in order
traversal you're going to begin the
search at the left most node and in the
the rightmost node so you can see this
this just has all the numbers in order 3
4 5 6 7 9 10 17 20 22 so there's all
these numbers in order
you're gonna begin at the left notes
most note and you're gonna add all the
numbers in order now preorder traversal
you can explore the root nodes before
the leaves so let's look at this I'm
gonna read off these numbers down here
and I'm going to show up on the picture
where they are in the picture so we're
looking at the root nodes first in the
list 9 is first that's a root node then
4 that's a root node then 3 and the next
newt is gonna be six and then five and
then seven then 17 and then 10 which we
don't have on this picture then 22 than
20 this is a pre-order focuses on the
root nodes first and then adds that
their notes below that the postorder
explores the leaf nodes before the roots
so look at this one the first node on
the list is 3 because it's a leaf all
the way down and then we have 5 because
that's a leaf node and then we have 7
and then we're gonna go to 6 we're not
gonna hop over to 20 over here because
that's not a completely different branch
of the tree you have to finish all the
leaf nodes on one branch before you go
to the next branch so after 6 is 4 now
is where we jump over the leaf nodes on
the next branch and we use 10 which
again is not on the picture then 20 then
22 then 17 and 9 this level order is
called a breadth-first search this
explores all the nodes in a given level
within a tree before continuing on to
the next level further it's going to do
level 0 which is 9 if you see these
numbers on here and the next line is
next is gonna show 4 and 17 then 3 6 22
then 5 7 20 so let's go over the code so
first we're gonna go over the code for
them main height and the find max ID and
then it is balanced so that is balanced
is pretty simple because you just call
these functions that I haven't talked
about yet but you na'kal find min height
and see if that's less than or equal to
find max height minus 1 so this is going
since this is a
a conditional statement is going to
return true or false so as an example if
you remember before we added the ten we
have the min height of one and the Mac
side of three if this Mac side is 3 3
minus 1 is 2 so is 1 less than or equal
to 2
no false so we know that the tree is not
balanced
we have false right here but then we run
it again down here and the max height is
3 and the min height is 2 if we do 3
minus 1 that's going to be 2 so now we
have is 2 less than or equal to 2
yes so we're gonna return true so that's
how we're gonna find out if it's
balanced now let's look at fine min
height this is going to be a recursive
function you can pass in a node but if
you don't pass in a node it's going to
set the node to the root node here and
then it's going to check if the node is
null and return negative 1 if you
haven't added anything to the binary
search tree it's gonna return negative 1
for the height we're gonna set the left
and right to calling the Fineman high on
the left and Fineman height node right
so this is where the function becomes
recursive eventually one of these two is
going to be negative one because the
left or right node is going to be null
so here we are going to add one to the
left if left is less than right and
we're going to add one to the right else
so if right is less than left and 4/5
find max Heights it's it's the opposite
so instead of having the less than here
we have the more than here so here we're
going to return left plus one as if left
is more than right else returned right
plus one feel free to check the code in
the description to play around with this
yourself the inorder preorder and
postorder there's a lot of similarities
to the code so let's look at the inorder
traversal first the only thing that's
going to be different and each of these
in order preorder and postorder are
these three lines and the only thing
that's going to be different in those
three lines is the order of the lines so
for all of them we're going to check if
the root is null and
in all this just to check if there's
even a binary search tree that exists or
if there's any values in it so if we
find out that there is a binary search
tree we're going to do these things
we're going to create a new array of the
result and we're going to add each value
in the in the tree onto the result so
we're going to create this function
traverse in order function and you can
see down here we're going to call that
function and pass in the root node and
then after the function has been run
you're going to return the result so
inside this function it's going to be
recursive and remember these three lines
are the only thing different between
inorder preorder and postorder it's
going to change the order that we check
things so in order we are going to first
do this line so this right here is
short-circuit evaluation
whenever JavaScript evaluates the and
operator like this if the first thing is
true it will also run the second command
if the first thing is not true it will
not run the second command check my
video on short-circuit evaluation to
find out more about that so if no dot
left is true that means if no doubt left
exists then we are going to run the
trench reverse in order function on no
dot left and that just calls the same
function again and passes n note that
left then we're going to push no dot
data so we're going to push the value in
that node onto the result array and then
we are going to check if no dot right
exists if it does we are going to call
the traverse in order function on no dot
right and if we look down here like
we're I said they're just these three
lines are different so in pre-order it's
going to push first and then it's gonna
call the function on note left and then
it's gonna call the function I know dot
right in post order it's going to call
the function on no dot left then I call
the function on node dot right and then
push the data so just to order that we
call these commands is going to
change the order of how we get the
result when traversing the tree again
you can check that code and play around
with it until you can figure out exactly
how it works I'm going to go down to the
level order function in this method we
start by adding the root node to a queue
then we begin a loop where we DQ the
first item in the queue add it to a new
array and then inspect both it's child
sub trees if it's children are not null
they are each in queued this process
continues until the queue is empty
we are treating a result array that we
are eventually going to return now
here's just that the queue array this is
just a temporary array that we're using
that we're eventually going to put
things off that ray onto our result
if this that root is not null if there
actually is a binary search tree we're
going to push the root node on to queue
and this is a while loop so it's gonna
continue going through this until we've
actually added all the all the elements
from the tree so while Q is the queue
length is more than 0 we're gonna keep
doing these things so first we're going
to let node equals Q dot shift now shift
just takes off the first element in the
array and returns that element so we're
gonna put the root node into node
because it started out as the root node
and now Q is not going to have that root
node on it anymore and we're going to
push no data onto that result
so we've just pushed 9 onto the result
and if you remember 9 is the first thing
in the the level order result now if no
debt left does not equal null we are
going to push no left onto the queue and
if no dot right is not equal now we're
gonna push note that right onto the the
queue and then then we're going to go
back through the while loop
we're gonna take off the first node and
put into node which remember is going to
be no doubt left so we pushed on here
and we are going to push that value to
the results we're going to push forward
to the result and now we're going to
push no doubt left and we're gonna push
no dot right so in the queue we're not
gonna have 3 and 6 but when we go back
through the while loop
and we shift off an element even though
we added three and six in the last
iteration of the loop the know that
we're shifting off is going to be 17
because shift is going to take the first
item of the array off and three and six
are at the end of the array so then it's
going to get that value and so on it's
going to keep going through this until
it's got every value from the tree
a hash-table is used to implement
associative arrays or mappings of key
value pairs hash tables are a common way
to implement the map data structure or
objects they are widely used because of
how efficient they are the average time
for each lookup is not tied to the
number of elements stored in the table
in fact the average time complexity of
hash tables and big notation is o of 1
for a search insert and delete that's
very fast the way a hash table works is
that it takes a key input and then runs
it through a hash function a hash
function basically just Maps strings to
numbers and usually the numbers just
correspond to indexes in an array so for
example here are the strings we pass
through the hash function and then we
get the numbers over here a hash
function needs to be consistent so when
you run a key through the hash function
it always gives the same number and it
should map different words to different
numbers if two words get hashed to the
same number this is called a collision
you can see in this example John Smith
gets hashed to two Lisa Smith gets
hashed to what was ero 1 Sam go for and
then Sandra Dee also gets hashed to 2 so
this is a collision because both of
these names once they run through the
hash function get turned into the same
number or the same index for the array
one way to handle collisions is just to
store both key value pairs at that index
then upon lookup of either you would
have to iterate through the bucket of
items to find the key you are looking
for this could take a little extra time
because of the iteration so here's
another example where it's showing that
the names are going through the hash
function and then it's showing basically
the information that's being stored in
the bucket so this would be the array
index and then in that array index or
the bucket we would store the phone
number so this would be like a phone
book the numerical value from the hash
function is then you
as the index to store that information
then if you try to access the same key
again the hashing function will process
the key and return the same numerical
result which will then be used to look
up the associate value which just means
that once you store all these things in
the array once you want to get the
number again you would just pass in the
key John Smith into the hash function it
would give you the exact same array
index too and then you would get the
information returned to you which is the
phone number
now you will probably never have to
implement hash tables yourself because
most languages including Java Script
already have them built-in in JavaScript
hash tables are usually used to
implement objects however it can be
helpful to see how they are implemented
just to gain a better understanding so
I'm going to show you the code for a
hash table so you can see how they work
first of all we have our hash function
where we're gonna pass in the string
that we want to hash and then the Max
Max is the number of buckets that we're
using in our hash table to store values
we're gonna start with hash being zero
and we are going to for each character
in the string string that link for as
long as the string is we are going to
add the care code of each character each
string character has a numerical value
associated with it so basically we're
just adding up the character codes for
each character in the string and putting
into the hash now instead of returning
the hash we're gonna return hash modulus
max that just means we are going to
divide by the number of buckets and then
return the remainder so if we had 5
buckets if we're divided by 5 the
remainder is either going to be 0 1 2 3
or 4 and then that would be the index
that we're going to place the item into
the array now this is a very simple hash
function just for an example but they
can get much more complicated now let's
go into the hash table function so in
the hash table function we're gonna have
our storage array which is where we're
going to store all the
data we're putting into it and the
storage limit now this is the number of
buckets in the array at first I'm just
gonna show you with just four different
buckets but normally actually this
number will be much higher and this is
just a utility function just for this
example so I can easily print all the
items in this storage array I can easily
log them so here's where the real
methods come in for the hash table if we
want to add some information so first
you're gonna pass in a key and a value
we're gonna figure out the index of the
array by running it through the hash
function so we create this hash function
where we're gonna pass in the key and
the storage limit the number of buckets
that we're gonna have in our hash table
and that's going to return an index that
we went over before if there's nothing
in that index in the storage array if
it's undefined we're just going to set
that index to be this key value pair
array else if it's not undefined that
means there's already something in that
bucket so first we're gonna set insert
it to false and then we're gonna go
through each index to see if the key
already exists if the key already exists
we're gonna set the new value here and
set insert true if the key does not
exist then insert is still gonna be
equal to false so we're going to push in
the new item that's where we'll get
multiple entries into one bucket so the
next thing is if we're going to remove
an item from the hash table so if we're
gonna remove you're just passing the key
of what you want to remove and now we're
gonna look up the index by passing it
into the hash function if the index that
length equals one that means there's
only gonna be one item in that bucket
and the item in that bucket equals the
key that you passed in then you can just
delete that index you can just sleep
that item but if it does not equal one
that means there's probably a few
different items at that index and we
want to only delete the item associated
with that key so we're going to go
through each item in that bucket or in
the
index and if the key equals the key we
passed in then we can delete that item
the zero index is the key the one index
is the value so let's go how we would
look up an item again we're gonna set
the index using our hash function with
the key that we passed in and the
storage limit if the index there is
undefined we just return undefined it's
not the item is not in the hash table
else we're going to go through each
element in that bucket if the element
equals the key then we can return that
element
so let's look up a few examples first
I'm going to show you an example of the
hash function here if we run that to me
three and every time I run that you'll
see in the console three three three
every time I put Bo it's gonna put three
but if I put a different name here and I
run that you can see on the console it's
gonna be five and now every time I run
two has to be five so with this hash
function it's going to always be a
number between zero and nine because
we're passing in ten as the number of
buckets so now let's actually see the
hash table so here we're gonna create a
new hash table called hte for hash table
we're gonna add Bo who's a person add
find out who's a dog retsu the dinosaur
tux who's a penguin then we're gonna
look up tux and then we're just gonna
print the entire thing so let's see what
happens in the console so we saw that
tux is a penguin now let me bring this
over a little bit it's going to show our
entire hash table now normally you're
never gonna print out the hash table
like I did to the console but I just did
that just for learning purposes if you
remember up here we have the storage
limit set at four so we only have four
buckets the reason why I had it set at
four is so we will see what it looks
like when there's a collision when
there's two things in one bucket just by
coincidence the first buck is undefined
that means none of these words hashed to
zero and then if we look at the second
bucket that's right here there's
actually two key value pair
in the second bucket so both bow and tux
both gave one when it went through the
hash function and then you can see in
this bucket right here we just have one
item and then this bucket right here we
just have one item so when we pass in
reps to the hash function we got three
returned but if we go up here and we
change the number of buckets to
something like 14 now I'm gonna try
running that again if you look right
here now there's a lot more undefined
because most of the buckets are now
empty but this bucket only has one item
that book has one item and then the last
two books have one item and there are no
collisions now each bucket only has one
item now this has just been a pretty
simple example of a hash table
implementation but it's enough to give
you a basic idea of the hash table
a linked list is a common data structure
where elements are stored in a node the
node contains two key pieces of
information the element itself and
reference to the next node so in this
example the element here will be one and
then here's the reference to the next
note this arrows point to the two this
two is the element we're storing the
information to and the way this length
linking to the next node like arrays
linked lists can be used to implement
many other data structures linked lists
have some advantages and disadvantages
when compared to arrays traditionally
arrays are just have a fixed size and
linked lists have dynamic size so you
can just keep adding links and you don't
have to do anything differently
JavaScript kind of hides some of this
but when you create an array can only be
a fixed size also arrays have pretty
inefficient insertions and deletions
while linked lists are very efficient
search terms and deletions a benefit to
arrays are the random access which means
you can say you want something at index
five and you can instantly get the thing
at index five however with linked lists
if you want something at index five you
have to go through every element in the
linked list to get to index five and
then for arrays they may result on much
memory waste to make up for the fact
that arrays can only only be made at a
fixed size sometimes they will be
created a lot bigger than what you
really need to make sure you have enough
room for everything however in a linked
list because of the dynamic size there
is no wasted memory and then we have
really fast sequential access for raised
and slow for linked lists so every
linked list is gonna have a head so we
have this head pointer here that points
to the first node and then it's also
going to have a size so that's just the
amount of node so in this example here
the size will be three and you can see
each node points the next node in the
last node it just points to null because
there is no next node so if you look at
the code over here we start with the
head of null because we don't have a
head yet and the length is going to be
zero and the linked list is made up of
nodes so here's how we're going to
create a node we pass in an element and
this Telma is set to element this
next is set to null so this not element
in the picture is the info and this that
next in the picture is the link so it
starts off just like the last element
where the link is point to null next is
point to null then we just have a few
simple functions this step size just
returns the length and this the head
just returns the head and here's the add
function whatever we're going to pass in
to the linked list is going to be the
element so you're gonna add the element
and then we're gonna create a new node
with that element so after you pass in
the element and it creates this new node
the element of the node is set to the
element you passed in but the next of
the node is set to null so if head
equals null that means there are no
nodes in the linked list yet so we just
set the head to equal the node and at
that point there would just be one node
in the linked list and the head would be
pointed that first node else that means
there's more than one element list we're
gonna set the current node to equal the
head and let's add a var in front of
here so this just means that we're gonna
start at the head node which you always
have to do whenever you're doing
anything to a linked list you start the
beginning and then you to go through
each item in the list while current node
dot next that means while there is a
current door next while current node
that next does not equal null you can
see at the end remember the link equals
current node next so at the end it
equals null so before the end of the
list the current node next which would
be the link does not equal null it
equals the next node so this just means
while there is a next node current node
equals current node next so that's just
a way to hop from node to node on the
list once there is no current node next
that means we're at the end of the list
the end of the list is where we want to
add the element that we're adding now
we'll set current node next to equal the
node once we get to the last node in the
list we'll set the
Curnow dentin X or this link to equal
the new node we added instead of null
and we just increment the length the
remove method takes an element and
searches a linked list to find and
remove the node containing that element
so you're passing the element that you
want to remove and we always start at
the head current node equals head and
then we also need to know the previous
node when you're gonna remove something
so if the current node that element
equals element if current node element
equals element well that just means that
the head node is the element we're
trying to remove so if we're trying to
remove the head node we just have to set
the head to current node next so the
head pointer will be pointing to the
next node if the head node is not the
node we're looking for we go to the else
so else while current node to element is
not equal known element basically while
the node Ron does not equal the node
we're searching for previous node is
gonna equal the current node like I said
we have to keep track to the previous
node and then the current node is going
to equal current node next it just means
we're gonna keep going through this
while loop and keep jumping to the next
node on the list until we find the node
we're looking for let's let's say if
this second note on this example here
we're minus that previous node that next
to equal current node dot next if we're
trying to remove this second node we're
gonna step previous node next so the
previous node that next would be the
first node so there'll be the link the
link is now going to not point to the
current node the link is going to point
to the current node dot next we would
skip over that node and point to the
current node that next right here and
that's how a node would be deleted from
the linked list and then we just
decrement the link now here's another
quick function is empty return length
equals equals equals 0 so if filling T
equals zero we're going to return true
if it doesn't equal zero we're gonna
return false and you may want to know
the index of a specific element so we're
just gonna have to hop from node to node
until we find that element and then
return
index so the current node is gonna equal
head start at the beginning and next is
gonna start at negative one and so Wow
current no that means while there is a
current node while it's not null we're
gonna increment the index so at this
point we start the beginning we've
incremented the index so where the index
is now is zero so if current node that
element equals element returned index so
if the first element which would be this
info equals what we passed in up here
we're gonna return the index so if
instead of the head node we're gonna
return the index zero if not current
node equals current node next and then
when we continue doing this while loop
and just hop from node to node and then
then we're gonna eventually be able to
return the index as we keep adding one
to the index for every time we do the
while loop and if we go through all the
whole while loop and don't find anything
we're gonna return negative one that
just means the element is not in the
linked list so we just found the index
of an element now going to find the
element at an index that's just the
opposite you're passing an index number
and you're going to return the element
so we have current node equals head
count equals zero and here's the wall
loop here while count is less than index
that means we haven't gotten to the
index we're searching for increment
count and current node equals current
note that next so that means we hop to
the next node so we're gonna keep going
through every node in the list until
count is not less than index that means
count equals index so we've reached the
right index so we can just return
current node that element yep you're
gonna pass in the index and elements and
add remember we you always add to the
end of the linked list but an add at you
can add in the middle of the list so
just like a ID we're gonna create a new
node with the element we pass them and
the current node is gonna equal head we
always start at the beginning we need to
keep track to the previous node and the
current index is gonna equal zero
so if index is more than length that
means we've passing an index that's way
bigger than the actual length of the
linked list so we cannot add at the
index when we return false if index
equals zero that means we're trying to
add the element to the head node so
we'll set node n
or no it is a note that we just passed
in so the next element is now gonna be
the current node which would be the
current head node and then we just set
the head to equal the node that we
passed in else we don't want the index
to be the head node while current index
is less than index we're gonna go
through each index until we find the
correct index so cray index increment
we're gonna set the previous node to
equal the current node so we want to
keep track of the previous node the
current node is gonna equal current node
next we're gonna keep going through this
while loop until we find the correct
node so if we want to add a node as
index one or the second node on the list
once we get to that index we're gonna
set node X equal to current node so or
no debt next is the node we passed in
and we're gonna set that to equal the
current node which would be this index
right here then we have to set previous
node that next to equals and note that
we're passing in and then we just
increment the length and the last
function I'm gonna talk about is remove
it now remove it and a net are very
similar a lot of the lines are the same
except we're not gonna create a new node
the kernel is gonna be the head
we need a previous node the current
index is gonna be zero here is a
slightly different thing if the index is
less than zero or if the index is more
than or equal at length
return null so we cannot remove a
negative index and we cannot remove an
index greater than the length of the
list if index equals zero we're trying
to remove the head node so we just set
the head node to equal the current node
next so instead of the head pointer
point to this node right here that head
pointer is going to point to the next
node right here else this part is just
like the ad and we're just going to keep
going through each element on the list
and once we find the element we want to
remove like let's say we're removing
this second element at index one we're
going to set previous node next to equal
current node next we're going to set the
previous node next or this link is going
to point to whatever was in the link to
the current node or so this link is
going to point to now
this note right here and we're gonna
completely take out this one and then
we're gonna do length - - and return the
note that we're removing and now we're
just going to quickly show an example of
using the linked list we're going to
call the linked list conga because a
linked list is kind of like a conga line
and let me bring up the console so we're
gonna create this new linked list we're
gonna add some items kitten puppy dog
catfish we're gonna show the size we're
gonna remove the third item on the list
so we'll run them and see we're gonna
remove cat now let's copy this we're
gonna do element at then we'll try index
app and for the element we're gonna put
puppy look I mean index of so we remove
cat now we check the new element three
which is gonna be fish and the index of
puppy is gonna be one kitchen would be
zero copy is one and the size is four
well that's the linked list
a try that's how this is pronounced
right here a try sometimes called a
prefix tree is a special type of tree
used to store associative data
structures a try stores data in steps
each step is a node in the try this is
often used to store words since there
are a finit number of letters that can
be put together to make a string a
possible use case would be to validate
that a word is in a dictionary each step
or node would represent one letter of a
word so if you can see over here this is
an example of a try this word right here
will be B a ll ball the steps begin to
branch off when the order of the letters
diverged from the other words in the try
or when a word ends so if you get the
word be a ll but you also have be a T
bat so the first two letters ba are part
of the word ball and part of the word
bat and then down here you have doll do
dork and dorm if you look at the red
stars that just means it's at the end of
the word so the word do you can see it's
the end of a word even though there are
still letters in other words after the O
so let's look at the information in each
node from the code here each node is
going to have a keys which is just a new
map and this is the es6 map structure
it's kind of like an object it has just
key value pairs and in the in these keys
the key value pairs are kind of like the
name of a folder in a folder in a
directory structure so if you can
imagine these all folders in the root
node there is the keys map that's going
to have B D and s and each of the key
value pairs are the B the name of this
folder is the key in the map and the
value of that key is the folder be the
actual contents of the folder B and so
that D is
key in the map and the value the key
value pair the value is going to be the
actual contents of the folder
each snows gonna have a list of keys
which is just a list of all the other
letters that are inside that folder or
in that inside that note and then we're
gonna have an end data that just means
is this the end letter in a word so in
this picture all of the node with a star
have end set to true and all the nodes
without a star have end set to false now
we just have a setter function set end
and is equal to true is end so it's just
gonna return true or false if it's the
end of the word so now that we've looked
at each node in the try let's look at
how the code to the actual try set up so
we're going to only going to have three
functions we're gonna have add to add a
word to a try we're gonna have is word
to see if a word is a word in the try
and then print this is more of kind of
like a helper function just to print all
the words that are in the try so before
I go through the code let me show you
how it be used what we're gonna create a
new try and then we'll get you can add
the words like this and then after you
add all these words and these are the
same words are in this picture over here
you can check if it is a word is dollar
word well doll is gonna be word is
daughter word see we have the word do R
in the picture but there's no star on
our because door is not a an actual word
even though those letters are in the try
and then Dorf well check do R and then
there's no F so that's not a word and
you can just print the whole thing like
that so if I run that you're gonna see
in the console down here true false
false and then you can see the whole
list here so let's go back up to here
first of all we're gonna create the root
node a new node and then let's look at
the ad function so this ad function is a
recursive function so when you call it
for the first time you're gonna put the
entire word you want to add to the try
and that becomes the input and theer
says note equals this dot root that
means
if you pass in a note it will use that
node but if you don't pass in a node it
will just use this that root as the
default node so if input that length
equals equals zero that means if we're
at the end of the word that we passed in
we're just going to do no dot set end
and then return and we're done with the
add function else if that means if
there's more than zero letters that
we've passed into this add function
we're not at the end of the word so
first we're going to check if there's
already a node with that letter that
we're looking at so this is if not no
dot keys that has so let's say we're in
the root node no duck keys is a list of
all the letters of that root note points
to so if it does not has if it does not
have a letter input zero would just mean
the first character of the string we
passed in so if we pass in ball it would
this is just saying if there is not a
node with the letter B here then we are
going to create a node with the letter B
know that keys that set set is how we're
going to create a new key value pair in
the keys map we're going to set it with
the key to be the letter input zero so
input was you don't bracket just means
the first letter of the input would pass
in so if we pass in ball the first
letter to me B and so remember each key
value pair is then Nate is kind of like
the name of a folder and the contents of
the folder the name of the folder is B
the contents of the folder are a new
node so then this is where it becomes
recursive we're gonna call this dot add
and we're gonna pass in inputs abstract
one which takes the input and takes
every letter after the first letter and
passes it into the add function again so
if the word was ball every letter after
the first letter is a ll so we're gonna
just pass in the letters all and we're
also gonna pass in a node before
remember twister
there with the root node now we're gonna
pass in this node which is also the node
we just created here so we're gonna set
a node with the letter B that'll be the
input 0 so now we're gonna get the node
with the input 0 that's the first
character so now we're gonna run the add
function but instead of after being at
the root node we're gonna be at the the
node B and then the else is just if
there is already a letter by that name
so remember here we added a node with
the letter B but if there already is a
letter B like for instance let's say we
already have the word doll and we're
gonna add the word dork if we're at the
D and the word doll is already in the
Tri and we want to add dork well O is
already going to be in the Tri so if I
was already in the Tri we're not going
to create the own ode we're just going
to add the the new sub string which in
this case would be so our k we're gonna
add that to the nodes that know that
keys that get input 0 which would be the
O node so we're gonna keep running
through that until we've added the word
to the Tri and then down here we're
gonna check if the word is in the Tri so
this is where the Tri really performs
you can check if a word is in the
dictionary
much quicker in the Tri than other data
structures because we don't have to
check through every word we're just
checking one letter at a time so we're
passing in the word we're setting the
node to the root node at first and then
this is the loop that we're gonna keep
running through until we find the word
so while we're dot linked as more than
one while there's more characters to
search in the the word that we passed in
so if not no duckies that has word this
is saying we're gonna check the first
character in the word so let's say we're
on the root node so if there is no key
with the first character in the word
like let's say we passed a word tree
well there's no T there's no key with
the letter T here so we can return false
we quickly determined that that word
three is not in this try because there's
no word that starts with T else that
just means there must be a word that
starts with that letter so let's say
we're looking for the word it's end well
if it does have the letter S then we're
going to do these two things we're gonna
set the note remember which we used to
be the root note but now we're gonna set
the node to the the note s because if
we're gonna look for the word descend
we're sorting the note to the S note and
we're gonna change the word into the
word - the first character so now we're
just gonna be looking for the word end
instead of sindh so I'm gonna go back up
here now we're we're gonna keep running
through this now we're on the S note but
we're looking for the word end and yeah
we'll find the e we'll find the end and
we'll find the D and now we go to this
very last line if note that key that has
word which would just be a single letter
because remember we keep taking the
letters off and so if it has the last
letter of the word that we passed in and
it is the end so is end then we're gonna
return true that word is in the Tri else
we're gonna return false yeah so this
last one was just the the print function
that's kind of a helper function and so
we're gonna create an array of every
word but right now it's just gonna be
empty then when a search we're gonna
pass in or a search if we don't pass
anything here it's gonna set this is a
root node actually that we don't even
need this let me just run that just to
see if it does the same thing in the
console yep we don't even need to set
the note to the root node because when
we first call the search command down
here we already passed in this dot root
so we're just gonna pass in a node and
we're gonna pass in a string here if no
duck keys that size does not equal zero
that means they're still still more
letters to look through so for each
letters and the keys here let's say
we're on the root node so the letters in
the key would be B D and s so for each
of those letters we're going to run the
search command again and then we're
gonna pay
Sen note keys that get letter that means
we're going to pass in the the node at
that letter so we would pass in the B
node and then we're going to add that
letter to the string at the beginning
the string would be empty so do string
that can concatenate one letter we're
going to add the letter B and basically
since this is recursive it's going to
keep going and keep adding each letter
so we keep Concannon each letter to the
string until it's formed the whole word
and then see if node that is end if
we've gone to the last node in the word
it's going to do word dot push string so
that's our word to raid if we've gone to
the last letter in the word we're gonna
push the word onto the words array no
else that's else to this if statement if
the note keys that size does equal zero
then we're at the last letter of a
branch if string that length is is more
than zero we're just gonna push that
word on to the words array or else
returned undefined and here's where we
call that a search function for the
first time so here's the search function
and then we call for the first time and
this is gonna go over and over until it
gets every word in the try if words that
length is more than zero it's gonna
return that where the words the words
array or it's gonna return all if
there's no words in the array so that's
a try
a binary heap is a partially ordered
binary tree which satisfies the heap
property it has some similarities to a
binary search tree except the order is a
little different each node has at most
two child nodes the heap property
indicates a specific relationship
between the parent and child nodes you
may have a max-heap in which all parent
nodes are equal than or greater to than
the child nodes so you can see the the
biggest numbers on top and the smallest
numbers are on bottom or you may have a
min heap in which all child nodes are
greater than or equal to the parent
nodes so the child nodes are the biggest
ones and the parent nodes are the
smallest ones the order between child
nodes on the same level does not matter
so you have 10 6 and 12 here here we
have 5 6 & 1 you can see that it goes
from a small number to a big number to a
small number the order doesn't matter if
they're on the same level binary heaps
are also complete binary trees this
means that all levels of the tree are
fully filled and if the last level is
partially filled it is filled from left
to right so if you see the example down
here so here's level one then we have
level two here level three level three
is all the way filled level four is only
partially filled because there's nothing
over on the right side here but you can
see it's filled from left to right
binary heaps may be implemented as tree
structures with nodes that contain left
and right references like what I showed
in my binary search tree video however
heaps are more often implemented as
arrays this is possible because of the
partial ordering according to the heap
property we can just compute the
parent-child relationship of the
elements now this will make a lot more
sense with this diagram here so if you
see this array right here this is the
array representation of this tree right
up here the number 1 is 20 and that's
the root you can see that right up here
and then 2 & 3 are the child knows 19
and 17 right here and now I want to pull
your attention over to these equations
up here so that the left child is going
to be I times 2 the right child can be I
times 2 plus 1 let me show you what that
means so if you look at
20 here which is at index 1 in the array
also I should point out that there is no
index 0 so when you're representing a
heap you're just gonna leave index 0 as
null to make the math work out a little
better so if we go back to index 1 well
the equation for the left shell is I
times 2 so 1 times 2 will be 2 so yeah
19 is the left child and the right child
is I times 2 plus 1 so 1 times 2 plus 1
is 3 17 that's the right child now let's
say we go to number 13 here
that's index 4 well if we go to the
equation I times 2 4 times 2 is 8 so if
your index 4 and you go to index 8 11
yep that's the left child now we start
index 4 and we do the right child
equation I times 2 plus 1 that's 9 so if
we go to index 9 yep that's the right
child here so that's how you can use
these equations to find the left and
right child from an array representation
you can also figure out the parent so
the equation for a parent I divided by 2
if we are on 11
that's index 8 8 divided by 2 is 4 index
4 and this really should be floor I
divided by 2 because you divide the
index by 2 and then round down to the
nearest whole number
for instance 5 divided by 2 is 2 point 5
but if you round out it's 2 and then 2
would be the the index 19 here also you
can see in this diagram that the last
index is also the size of the heap size
10 this diagram is a max-heap I'm going
to show you the code for a min heap but
in the same file down here we I also
have the code for the max heap down here
so you can check the link in the
description so you can review this
actual code yourself and you can review
the maxi on your own but like I said
we're just gonna review the the men heap
right now but before I show you the
actual code I want to show you a visual
representation of how it works when
you're inserting and you're removing
items from the heap those are the main
two commands insert and remove and then
there's one more I'll show you at the
end but let me show you this
representation here so you can see this
is the array representation and I'm
going to insert some numbers and you'll
see them show up as a tree
representation so let's see 4 you can
see 4 goes at the top that's the the
root node and now I'm going to put in 6
6 just goes down to the bottom there 8
so as it builds the node one thing to
keep in mind is that it's gonna build
one level of the tree at a time I'm
gonna put in 10 that's gonna be on the
very left side now so far I've been
putting them in order but now I'm gonna
put in the number 5 here and when I
insert the number 5 you're gonna see
this it's gonna first go to the end of
the array here you'll see their array
which is gonna first appear right down
here and then it's going to move up to
the correct position so let's see that
so then as you see it checks what
position to move it up to so I'm going
to put in a few other numbers here see
16 3 ok so you see it always puts in at
the end of the array or the end of the
tree and then it moves it up to the
correct position now I'm going to show
one more where I put in one where it's
gonna put it put it down here and it's
gonna move it all the way up to the top
and it's a check one at a time to see if
it has to move it up also another thing
would just be removing what when you
remove you always just remove the
smallest it's gonna remove what's in
index 1 which is always gonna be the
smallest and then it's gonna pop the
last node to the first node and then
it's going to sort them so let's see how
that works so did you see that so it
moved the last node to the first node
and then it has to keep checking and
keep moving it down until it gets to the
right position so let's move remove 3
okay so now let's go to the code and you
can see how that works
in the code so before we insert anything
you can see that we've created a heap
with an array that just has one item and
it's the item null at index zero so when
we insert something we pass in a number
and we're gonna push that number on to
the end of the heap so if you pass in
the number three there's going to be
index zero is null and next one would be
three now if the length of the heap is
more than two that means there's more
than one item in the heap if it's less
than two there's one or zero items in
the heap and that makes things really
easy but let's say it's it's more than
two so we're gonna let the index equal
heap dot length minus one so that means
we're finding the last index and the
heap while heap at that at the last
index is less than heap and then see
this equation right here that is the the
parent equation so now we're saying if
the last item in the the array which is
the item we just inserted right here if
the last time of the array is less than
its parent well if it's less than its
parent we're gonna have to move it up
because the smallest numbers have to be
at the top in the men heap so if the
index is more than or equal to one that
means if we haven't reached the root
node then we're going to do this now
this is es6 destructuring syntax which
just means we are gonna switch the node
we just inserted with the parent node
we're gonna we're gonna switch them so
here is the parent node here is a node
we just inserted and now we're gonna
switch them so the node we just inserted
is gonna be first and then the parent
node is gonna be next so it's just a way
to swap them for more information about
the es6 destructuring you can check out
my video about that topic so if math
math dot floor index divided by two is
more than one this just means if the
parent node is not the root node because
remember this is the equation for the
parent node
is the index of the root node so if the
parent node is more than the root node
then we're gonna set the index to map
that floor and X divided by two that's
the parent node which if you remember up
here we just put the number we passed in
into the parent node so now the index is
still gonna refer to the number we just
passed in because that number has went
into the parent node and so now we're
going to set the index to that node and
since this is a while loop or when I
keep going through this and we're going
to keep switching the the node to its
parent node as long as it is smaller
than the parent node else break so once
it's not smaller than the parent node we
just get out of this while loop and
that's the insert so let's go down to
remove it's a little more more code but
it's some similar concepts so we are
always going to remove the top node the
smallest node so we're gonna let this
smallest equal heap 1 so that just means
that the first node in the array is the
smallest node so that's the easy part
the hard part is rearranging the array
after you've removed that node so if
heap that length is more than 2 that
just means we have more than one node in
in the tree we're going to set the first
node in the tree which remember was the
smallest node but we're gonna set this
to the last node the last node in the
array now gets moved to the first node
in the array now we're gonna heap that
splice keep that length minus 1 this
just shortens the array by 1 so we just
removed the hole the last index of the
array completely since we've already
moved that to the first index if heap
that length equals 3 that means there's
only two numbers in the the tree and
that makes things really easy just if
one is bigger than the other then we
just switch them this is the
destructuring syntax again so if the
first one is bigger than the second one
then we switch it so the second one is
bigger than the first one and then we
just return the smallest if there are
more than two nodes in the array that's
where it gets slightly more complicated
so we're just going to set the index to
equal 1
we're gonna set the left equal two times
I and the right equals two times I plus
one remember that was just that the
equations from up above the equations
right here we're just putting him into
our formula down here now technically
you would not need to put this equation
here since we know that I equals one you
could just put three here you just put
four here but this is just so you know
we're using the equations from above so
we're one is the root notes or starting
with the runo so while the root note is
more than or equal to its left child or
the root note is more than or equal to
its right child
we're gonna do everything in here that
means we're going to have to basically
move a down and keep moving it down
until we get to the appropriate spot so
if the the left node is more than the
right node then we're going to switch
the root node with the left node this is
the destructuring syntax again so we're
gonna just swap the nodes so for
instance we would be swapping if we're
on this node and this node we just swap
those two nodes and then we're gonna set
the index to the left node so gonna set
the index to be the node that was at the
top node but has now been swapped else
that means the right node is less than
the left node we're gonna switch the
node with the right node so we're just
gonna swap with the right node and then
we just set the index to be the right
node so the the node just moved down a
little bit and then we set the index to
point to the node that we just pushed
down a little bit and then we have to
set the new left and right node so we
would set the left and right no to be
the left and right of the the one we
just passed down and then if the the
left child or the right child equals
undefined that means we're at the very
bottom of the tree so we can just break
out of this while loop and if it's not
undefined we just keep going through
until we find the place where the node
that we're moving down the tree is not
more than equal to the left node and is
not more than or equal to the right node
else if it's only equals two that means
there should be only one element in the
array so we just cut off the last
element else we reach our null that
means there were zero elements than the
to begin with and then widgets can
return the smallest element which is
just the element we just set up here the
last thing I'm going to talk about is
this now a common use case for the heap
data structure is for heap sort this is
one of the most efficient sorting
algorithms with average and worst-case
performance of o of n log in heap sort
works by taking an unsorted array adding
each item in the array into a men heap
and then extracting every item out of
the man heap into a new array the men
heap structure ensures that the new
array will contain the original items in
least to greatest order so this is the
function that you would use to do that
heap sort the hard part is creating the
all the code we just already went over
and this is just gonna use that code so
let result equals new array while heap
that length is more than one we're gonna
do with this that remove so we're gonna
remove the element on top of the tree
and we're gonna push onto the result and
we're going to keep doing that until
we've moved removed all of the smallest
elements and push it on to the result
and it's going to put the elements in
order well that's all I'm going to talk
about for heaps feel free to check out
this code and create your own heap and
and add some items and remove some items
just to see how it works
the graph data structure is not the same
as a graph you may have learned about a
math class graphs are collections of
things and the relationships or
connections between them the data in a
graph are called nodes or vertices the
connections between the nodes are called
edges one example of graphs is a social
network where the nodes are you and
other people and the edges are whether
two people are friends with each other
there are two major types of graphs
directed and undirected undirected
graphs are graphs without any direction
on the edges between nodes directed
graphs are graphs with a direction and
its edges an example of an undirected
graph could be a social network the
nodes are people and the edges are
friendships an example of a directed
graph could be the internet and web page
links the nodes are web pages and the
directed edges are links to other pages
which might not necessarily point the
other way I'm going to show you three
ways to represent a graph the first way
is called an adjacency list this
representation for a graph associates
each vertex in the graph with the
collection of its neighboring vertices
or edges in this image a is connected to
B B is connected to a and C and C is
connected to B this is how you could
show a relationship with texts and here
is how you could show this adjacency
list with JavaScript this is an
undirected graph because it does not
show the direction of the edges this can
also be more simply represented as an
array where the nodes just have numbers
rather than string labels another way to
represent a graph is to put it in an
adjacency matrix an adjacency matrix is
a two-dimensional array where each
nested array has the same number of
elements as the outer array so it's
basically a matrix of numbers where the
numbers represent the edges zeroes means
there is no edge or relationship and
ones means there is a relationship this
table shows an adjacency matrix to
represent
you can see that the labels for the
nodes are on the top and left now here's
a JavaScript representation of the same
thing unlike an adjacency list each row
of the matrix has to have the same
number of elements as nodes in the graph
here we have a 3 by 3 matrix which means
we have 3 nodes in our graph an
adjacency matrix can be used to
represent a directed graph here's a
graph for the second node has an edge
pointing toward the first node and then
the third node has an edge pointing to
the second node
notice how the numbers in the array
change there are only ones where a node
is pointing toward another node and
since there are only two points there
are only two nodes the final way I will
show to represent a graph is an
incidence matrix like the adjacency
matrix an incidence matrix is a
two-dimensional array however the rows
and columns means something else here
the adjacency matrix use both rows and
columns to represent nodes and incidence
matrix uses roads rose to represent
nodes in the columns to represent edges
this means that we can have an uneven
number of rows and columns each column
will represent a unique edge also each
edge connects two nodes to show that
there is edge between two nodes you will
put a 1 in the two rows of a particular
column as you can see in the diagram
edge one is connected to nodes a and B
now look at the column for edge 1 in the
incidence matrix table you will see a 1
in both the a row and the B row this
shows the edge 1 connects to nodes a and
B here is a directed graph for a
directed graph use 1 for an edge leaving
a particular node and negative 1 for an
edge entering a node and here is a
JavaScript implementation of the
incidence matrix graphs can also have
weights on their edges so far we have
unweighted edges where just the presence
and lack of edges binary 0 or 1 you can
have different weights depending on your
application a
different way is represented as a number
greater than one well now you know about
different types of graphs and how to
represent them in JavaScript
I'm gonna talk about how to find the
distances between two nodes in a graph
this is one of the main uses of graphs
and is called graph traversal traversal
algorithms are algorithms used to
traverse or visit nodes in a graph the
main types of traversal algorithms are
breadth-first search and depth-first
search in this video I will be showing
how to implement breadth-first search in
JavaScript as you can see the algorithm
starts at one node first visits all its
neighbors that are one edge away then
goes on to visiting each of their
neighbors the point is to determine how
close nodes are to a root node there are
different ways to implement
breadth-first search in this version you
pass in an adjacency matrix graph and
the index of the root node remember an
adjacency matrix each nested array in
the matrix shows which nodes in the
graph are connected to the node at that
index for example this array is at index
0 so it shows which nodes that node 0 is
connected to if it is connected to a
node there is a 1 at that index but if
it is not connected there's a 0 at that
index before I go through the code let's
see it in action so here is a graphical
representation of this adjacency graph
check out my previous graph video to see
how this adjacency graph goes into this
graph so we ran the breadth-first search
function we passed in this graph up here
and then we pass then the number 1 so
that means we're trying to find out how
far away every node is from the first
node so you can see this graphical
representation of the exact same graph
and if you see the first node right here
that's to know we passed in to the the
breadth-first search function we're
gonna see how far away each node is so
you can see right here it shows how far
away is so node 0 is 2 nodes away see
because of the direction of the graph we
can't just go straight across as 0
first from one we good at to then we go
to zero that's two nodes away one the
the note itself is always zero notes
away and then the second note is one
note away just one third note is three
nodes away see if first you have to
start at one then you go to 2 then 0
then three so that's three hops and four
is infinity because when you're not from
the first note it's impossible to get to
the fourth node because the fourth note
only points back to the first node this
function will output an object of key
value pairs where a key is the node and
the value is its distance from the root
this object will be used to store the
distances to the root node we will start
all the distances at infinity which in
this version of breadth-first search
indicates that a node is not reachable
from the start node here the distance
the root node from the root node is set
to zero instead of infinity we are going
to create a simple queue to keep track
of nodes to visit and the purpose of
this variable is to keep track of the
current node that we are traversing now
we will start a while loop to keep
traversing nodes until there are no more
nodes in the queue to traverse we'll
start the loop by popping off a node
from the queue to traverse which at the
beginning is the root node here we get
all the nodes connected to the current
node remember each index of the graft is
an array that shows what nodes are
connected to the root node associated
with that index so in this example we
are first looking at node 1 at node 1
the array show is that it is connected
to nodes 0 & 2 now we set the neighbor
index variable to an empty array this
will keep track of a list of nodes that
are connected to the current node
this lime gets the first note connected
to the current node when it says index
of one this finds the first connected
node because the number one in our array
means that the node is connected to
another node at that index if there is
no node with an index of one the index
variable will be set to negative one so
while index does not equal negative one
push the index onto our list of
neighbors this line searches for the
next connected node we look for the next
one in the array starting after the
previous one we found that's what this
plus one means now that we know all the
nodes connected to the current node we
loop through these connecting nodes and
get the distance if the value in the
nodes Lin array at the index of the
neighbor from the neighbor index array
equals infinity that means we haven't
set the distance of that node yet so we
will set now we are going to set it to
the value of the the nodes length array
for the current node plus 1 then we'll
push that neighbor to the queue so the
next time we go through the while loop
we'll check the neighbors of that node
to this for loop is the most complicated
part of this and you may have to read
through a couple times to completely
understand it at the end we returned the
nodes length array and that's
breadth-first search of a graph thanks
for watching my name is beau Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good